is it good for bitcoin if jp morgan
goldman sachs and bank of america issue
10 trillion dollars of usd stable coins
and start handling bitcoin and selling
it to all their institutional investors
yeah it's good for bitcoin bitcoins go
into a million dollars a coin than 10
million dollars a coin and all the
people that believed in bitcoins for the
last decade are going to have the
financial wherewithal to create their
own companies to do whatever they want
it's just not good for the entrepreneurs
that compete against the mega cops we
recently have seen a bunch of
politicians all start to pay attention
in various ways so we've got on one side
um in the united states most politicians
uh started off abrasive so you know
without naming any of them uh there's a
number that we're very concerned about
bitcoin uh if you go back a couple of
years we then saw uh obviously china go
ahead and ban miners um and take a
pretty abrasive uh step there but over
the last let's call it i don't know
eight months seven months uh we've seen
el salvador go ahead and make bitcoin
legal tender they seem to not only be
supporting it as legal tender they also
are onboarding people via their this uh
app that they've built and also this atm
network that they've built they're
mining bitcoin and kind of really trying
to plug their country if you will into
the bitcoin network and then just
recently over the last week or two we've
seen multiple politicians all at the
local level start to become much more uh
friendly or uh embracing of bitcoin so
you've got obviously the mayor in miami
who has been a very kind of pro bitcoin
for a while you've got eric adams who's
the new mayor of new york city he's now
leaning in saying he's going to take
some of his paychecks in bitcoin and
some of the stuff should be taught in
schools etc we've also got two kind of
smaller mayors one in tennessee and one
in i think it's tampa bay uh in florida
all kind of leaning into this
how do you look at the intersection of
bitcoin and politicians and it's just
this just a continuation of like bitcoin
is good for business and so if it's good
for corporations then it's going to be
good for the politicians as well or how
do you read that situation
i think that um
one of the great advantages of bitcoin
is
is
it's money of the people it's money for
the people
and
the combination of the fact that it's
permissionless and it's open
nobody controls it means everyone
everyone can adopt it everyone can
engage in it and the proof of work
network
means that you have
a large business
in bitcoin mining and what is bitcoin
mining bitcoin mining is like this it's
like your skin it's like it's
it's the first line of defense of your
immune system right it's what uh makes
you healthy
the bitcoin mining industry is a 22
billion dollar a year industry right now
that means that the protocol is creating
a 22 billion dollar subsidy
for
bitcoin entrepreneurs to go out into the
world and find supportive political
jurisdictions
22 billion dollars
and um
per year so when you think about that
that means that
um the miners themselves they have they
have to raise capital
but that but um you see the bitcoin
miners are ripping today in the market
right all their stocks are up yes and
they've been very successful you can
take a bitcoin miner public
you're not going to take a proof of
stake validator public right one of the
big
differentiators is
is the miners the miners
have to have to use energy and
technology
but the miners are also recruiting
political capital to the network